[Musique]
zone Europe sur sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de zone Europe sur Radio
sensation et sur TV 78 une émission
spéciale enregistrée en Italie l'Italie
pays de 59 millions d'habitants membres
de l'Union européenne depuis le 1er
janvier 1958 membre de l'espace Schengen
depuis le 26 octobre 1997 et membre de
la zone euro depuis le 1er janvier 1999
voici le sommaire de cette émission
rencontre avec des élèves d'un lycée
Professionnel des Hautes-Alpes en
mobilité à Rome un stage pour se
perfectionner en italien et découvrir le
monde du travail
la promotion du cinéma français en
Italie la 13ème édition du festival
rendez-vous avec le nouveau cinéma
français c'est tenu à Rome culture
toujours nous vous ferons découvrir la
vie de la Medicis l'Académie de France à
Rome accueille des auteurs des artistes
et des chercheurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le programme de mobilité et d'échange
Erasmus plus vient de fêter ses 35 ans
tous les profils sont concernés des
élèves de Bac Pro d'un lycée
Professionnel des Hautes-Alpes ont passé
4 semaines en stage ici à Rome dans un
théâtre un magasin d'électroménager ou
dans différentes boutiques rencontrent
avec leur formatrice Julia carasse
zone Europe
bonjour Julien casse vous êtes
professeur d'italien au lycée
professionnel Pierre Mendès France Avène
dans les Hautes-Alpes vous organisez
depuis 2017 de mobilité à Rome un
travail qui demande on imagine beaucoup
d'engagements personnels quels sont les
filières qui sont concernés par ces
échanges
c'est plutôt les filières commerces donc
on trouvait des stages juste dans des
petits magasins dans le centre de Rome
et depuis 2018 justement on a impliqué
aussi les sections électrotechniques qui
d'habitude n'ont pas de langue vivante
mais là pour ce
projet ils font de langues vivantes en
anglais italien et ça leur permet donc
de faire leur dernier stage ici à Rome
justement à l'Opéra de Rome où on en est
structures qui travaillent avec le
cinéma alors comment sont choisis les
élèves comment est-ce qu'ils sont
sélectionnés par la motivation par les
résultats scolaires plutôt par la
motivation on fait il y a tout un
questionnaire qui est fait par rapport à
la motivation à l'esprit d'équipe ou
alors maturité alors sérieux plus que
pas pour le résultat scolaire est-ce que
le fait de pouvoir avoir l'opportunité
donc de faire son son stage ici à Rome
est-ce que ça aide pour la motivation
lors des cours d'italien au lycée oui
carrément depuis la seconde ils savent
qu'ils ont la possibilité d'aller en
stage à Rome donc depuis par seconde
ceux qui veulent vraiment partir et ils
montrent un certain intérêt pour la
matière et on voit que les autres un peu
moins c'est un élément de motivation
supplémentaire on va dire ça permet
d'améliorer les résultats ou pas vous
avez noté des
après leur période de stage à l'étranger
souvent ils ont beaucoup ils ont gagné
beaucoup en maturité en autonomie donc
ça permet oui d'avoir des meilleurs
résultats au bac on voit il y a des
statistiques qui ont été faites parce
que l'italien c'est une langue
relativement facile à apprendre pour
pour des Français à l'oral c'est
relativement facile oui parce que ça
cette fois même bon
pareil après au niveau grammaticale
c'est assez compliqué mais on essaie de
pas trop en faire on essaie
professionnelle se baser plus sur l'oral
il y a beaucoup de liens historiques
culturels entre les deux pays est-ce que
vous vous en servez j'imagine lorsque
vous préparez vos cours d'italien oui je
m'en sers j'essaie de faire toujours des
ponts après comme je disais on travaille
beaucoup sur les sketchs les mises en
situation pour qu'ils sachent après une
fois arrivé ici en Italie se débrouiller
dans la vie quotidienne mais évidemment
il y a aussi des cours on insiste sur le
côté culturel par exemple ça fait très
longtemps que vous organisez des des
stages en Italie depuis 2017 ici à Rome
est-ce que c'est arrivé déjà que
certains élèves ont finalement été déçus
leur expérience non déçu l'expérience
n'ont jamais après au niveau des stages
bien sûr on a pas une réussite à 100%,
il y en a qui sont un peu surpris c'est
pas la même façon de faire qu'en France
il y en a qui disent qui on demande
moins de travail finalement s'ils
étaient en France mais l'expérience elle
est toujours très très riche très
simplement en quoi cette expérience ce
stage réalisé ici à Rome sont
enrichissants pour eux pour la suite de
leur parcours mais comme je disais ça il
gagne énormément en autonomie en
curiosité après ils ont une série de
diplômes qui vont passer à la fin de
l'année le repro le repas etc qui
pourront mettre dans leur CV mais aussi
au niveau vraiment personnel il se
rendent compte qu'il finalement qui sont
qui sont indépendants qui peuvent se
débrouiller tout seul dans une ville
dans une autre ville ou même un étranger
et donc ça leur ouvre vraiment les
possibilités de travail en Europe merci
beaucoup Julia d'avoir été avec nous
merci et puis maintenant on va justement
on a suivi deux de vos élèves Morgan et
Justine dans le cours de leur stage ici
à Rome
[Musique]
alors il y a des produits nouveaux donc
qui viennent d'Italie et de Germanier et
il y a aussi des produits vintage donc
qui viennent de ses amis et qu'elle
repeint ou qu'elle reforme pour les
revendre ensuite tu as beaucoup
progressé en anglais en italien depuis
que tu es arrivé ici à Rome alors en
italien oui
et je comprends beaucoup mieux l'italien
qu'avant et en anglais mais il y a
beaucoup de touristes donc j'ai appris
quelques mots et franchement oui comment
est-ce que tu trouves les clients ici
est-ce que ils sont différents en France
qu'il y a des similitudes
ici les clients ils sont vraiment sur
deux ils savent ce qu'ils veulent et ce
qu'ils veulent pas c'est aussi
l'occasion pour les tuteurs italiens
d'échanger leur expérience avec les
jeunes Français en quoi est-ce que c'est
enrichissant pour vous d'accueillir des
jeunes Français
parce que je suis une mère une
grand-mère et mes enfants ont déjà été
accueillis de cette manière dans le
passé et je trouve que c'est normal de
partager ses connaissances
du coup qu'est-ce que vous essayez de
leur transmettre comme valeur comme
compétence dans le cadre du travail
je trouve que c'est très important
d'être
la clientèle et comment tout simplement
faire le premier travail d'inventaire
des objets qui arrivent tous les jours
il y a toujours quelque chose à
apprendre mais c'est sur place que l'on
apprend le mieux
on va dans un autre magasin maintenant
on va retrouver Justine elle est en
stage dans une friperie bonjour je
m'appelle
Anne de friperie et en même temps de
nouveau donc ici nous avons tout ce qui
est vintage donc les clients viennent
apporter leurs vêtements et ensuite ils
ont une cagnotte donc en échange ils ont
de l'argent qui peuvent dépenser dans le
magasin ensuite nous avons ici tout ce
qui est du nouveau voilà comment ça
s'est passé tes premières semaines à
Aaron
alors la première a été très difficile
parce que le fait de prendre nos marques
et puis vivre avec d'autres gens dans un
autre mais dans un pays étranger c'est
pas non plus facile mais après quand on
est dans un bon stage vraiment ben c'est
super surtout que les patrons ben ils
sont au top aussi après ben c'est aussi
découvrir une nouvelle culture des
nouveaux monuments puis visiter fallait
vraiment c'est super intéressant en quoi
c'est une chance pour ton parcours
professionnel de pouvoir faire un stage
à Rome ça va t'apporter quelque chose en
plus
rouillé seul aussi donc avoir beaucoup
d'autonomie ensuite
m'adapter au contexte professionnel que
ça soit la langue c'est plein de choses
comme ça qu'on n'a pas l'habitude
qu'est-ce que tu dirais pour finir à
ceux qui hésiteraient à se lancer dans
une expérience que comme tu l'as fait
toi en Erasmus
vraiment foncé c'est une expérience à
vivre puis on n'a pas tous cette chance
là de effectuer un stage à étranger
maintenant je suis à Rome et vraiment
j'en suis super fière et puis quatre
semaines ça passe vraiment vite donc
vraiment foncé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
western spaghetti film d'auteur comédie
le cinéma italien est connu pour sa
richesse et sa diversité mais le cinéma
français n'a pas à rougir Rome
accueillir récemment la treizième
édition des Rendez-vous avec le nouveau
cinéma français rencontre avec Vanessa
Tonini directrice artistique du festival
13e édition cette année du festival
rendez-vous ici à Rome qui célèbre le
cinéma français comment est-ce que
justement notre cinéma est perçu à
l'étranger en Italie je pense qu'elle
est Ali c'est un des pays qui aime le
plus le cinéma français on a tous les
mois de sortie des films français il y a
eu une époque qui avait qui était
l'amour pour les comédies mais
maintenant ça devrait que tout le cinéma
français toujours en Seine en Italie je
pense qu'il y a un liaison très forte
que les italiens ont découvert tout le
nouveau cinéma on fait le festival
depuis 13 ans et on a vu vraiment
grandir le public alors le cinéma c'est
aussi un soft power important pour un
pays
oui je pense ah oui je pense que
je pense que oui toujours quand vous le
savez peut-être mais toujours quand il y
a le mot Paris dans le film tout le
monde arrive au cinéma mais je pense
qu'il y a une vraie attirance pour la
France de la partie italienne il y a une
connaissance qui est fort mais il est en
envie aussi de découvrir donc il y a un
amour très fort même pour il y a un
cinéma par exemple Guy Roady a fait
découvrir une partie de la France en
Italie c'est un des auteurs plus connus
en Italie il a fait découvrir le sud de
la France par exemple y a-t-il des
influences particulières entre entre le
cinéma français le cinéma italien et je
pense qu'il y a une dialogue mais ils
sont des cinémas très différents on a
des origines différents mais il a un
grand attirance et il y a certains
jeunes réalisateur qui maintenant
travaille beaucoup en France puis être
au marché par exemple vient de faire un
film il a il a fait un film son dernier
qui était presque complètement
production français donc je pense qu'il
y a un échange qui qui va devenir très
fort comme dans les années 60 quels sont
les films qui ont été sélectionnés cette
année pour ce festival et comment est-ce
que vous les avez choisi alors on a
beaucoup des films
on a quitté des avant-premières la
plupart partie sont des avant-première
italienne donc
ils vont sortir avec nous il y a des
expositions on prend parfois des films
qui sont été justement à Venise mais
simplement on fait cette exception avec
le festival des Venise par exemple la
Sinda calice qui était là et
sinon on a on aide les distributeurs
italiens à lancer leur film en Italie
mais on a aussi des filles qui sont pas
jamais encore pas vendus en Italie donc
c'est une sorte de vision qui ont fait
un cadeau au public italien de voir des
films qui peut-être ont trouvé un repas
une
distribution alors ce festival
rendez-vous c'est aussi l'occasion pour
les réalisateurs les acteurs de venir
ici à Rome rencontrer la salle aussi
poser des questions parler de leur film
les spectateurs c'est un atout aussi
pour eux c'est
à dire que les sciences avec les acteurs
et les réalisations sur les séances plus
populaires de c'est à dire qu'il y a
vraiment envie de changer à la fin du
film on a parfois aussi des master class
on a fait des master class dans le passé
avec des blessants avec Jacques Audiard
et et quand tu es et donc oui il y a
vraiment un avis de dialoguer sur le
film sur le thème de films sur le choix
des auteurs
aujourd'hui le cinéma de Nani Moretti
c'est un cinéma particulier aussi ah oui
c'est le cinéma à Rome c'est un cinéma
qui est aimé par le public et que c'est
un cinéma historique et nan il y a
toujours fait aussi des fruits des
filles français parce qu'il a un moment
donné il distribué aussi les films
d'alessand donc et c'est un peu pour
nous c'est la maison du festival et
poser les artistes c'est très
intéressant
il aime beaucoup de venir ici présenter
leur film comme ce soir aux gens et
rencontrer une année il y a un échange
entre professionnel entre artiste qui
est important et après donc Rome le
festival se poursuivra dans plusieurs
villes italiennes en Suisse oui la
plupart des fines sont montrés à Rome
mais on a des petits sections qui sont
des Rocky se déroulent dans des autres
villes à Palerme à Milano cette année à
torrent dans le cinéma que c'est un
endroit historique pour nous très
important pour le cinéma donc on essaie
de montrer aussi les films des
sélections des films et on fait aussi
voyager les artistes c'est cette année
coditore
qui habite et ils vont à Bologne et à
Palerme donc ils vont parler de leur
film dans des autres villes c'est
important pour le public italien
d'arriver aussi voir le film merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle donc vous êtes là
directrice artistique de ce festival
rendez-vous et pour promouvoir le cinéma
français les acteurs
réalisateur des films viennent ici les
présenter comme aujourd'hui François
Ozon on en a parlé on l'écoute tout de
suite pour moi c'est toujours important
de voyager avec mes films et j'aime
beaucoup l'Italie j'aime le cinéma
italien donc je suis très heureux que
mon film sorti en Italie avec la
distillerie la boîte de distribution BIM
qui avait sorti déjà plusieurs de mes
films notamment mes deux autres comédies
huit femmes et potiches donc là comme
c'est un peu le troisième volet de la
trilogie je suis heureux d'être à Rome
dans ce festival pour présenter le film
c'est toujours intéressant de voir les
réactions dans chaque pays à chaque fois
c'est différent mais en fait c'est une
histoire tellement française il y a
tellement un esprit français des
dialogues français que je suis toujours
curieux de savoir comment les étrangers
vont réagir je vais le savoir ce soir
puisque c'est la première projection
conformité donc je pourrais vous dire ça
dans deux heures mais pour l'instant je
sais pas encore j'espère qu'ils rirons
autant et que le film aura du succès
comme il a du succès en France
actuellement
[Musique]
j'aime vraiment quand la tromper
la mélodie
[Musique]
une soirée que tu
parfois on l'a entendu les artistes
français se mettent à l'italien tandis
que les Italiens eux aussi raffolent du
français d'ailleurs l'Italie est le
cinquième pays où l'on trouve le plus de
francophones au monde avec 11,8 millions
de locuteur et pour faire rayonner la
culture française la ville la Médicis
académie de France à Rome accueille des
auteurs des artistes et des chercheurs
j'ai rendez-vous tout de suite avec
Aurélie padovant elle est en charge de
la communication
c'est un lieu historique lié à la France
à l'accueil l'Académie de France une
institution qui a été fondée en 1666 par
Louis XIV c'est un lieu très riche en
histoire ici
tout à fait l'Académie de France à Rome
comme vous l'avez rappelé a été fondée
en 1666 par Louis XIV
et elle a accueilli plein de prix de
Rome donc ces artistes qui étaient
accueillis pour copier l'antique donc
pour s'inspirer des plus grands maîtres
italiens et aujourd'hui depuis 1803
l'Académie de France à Rome à son siège
ici à la Villa Médicis donc qui est un
palais Renaissance avec des jardins
étendus de cet hectare alors en 2023
quels sont les missions principales de
l'Académie de France justement à Rome
alors aujourd'hui l'Académie de France à
Rome à trois missions principale donc la
première de ces missions c'est donc
d'accueillir des résidences d'artistes
donc on accueille différents typologies
d'artistes de toutes disciplines
confondues la seconde mission très
importante c'est également de
d'organiser une programmation artistique
de très haute qualité encore une fois
une programmation pluridisciplinaire et
enfin on a également une mission très
importante de protection de valorisation
et de conservation du patrimoine de la
Villa autant le patrimoine bâti les
collections d'oeuvres d'art mais
également le les jardins alors vous
accueillez chaque année 16 pensionnaires
16 artistes par an ils sont sélectionnés
sur concours comment est-ce que ça tout
ça est organisé alors tout à fait on
accueille donc 16 pensionnaires comme on
les appelle donc ce sont des artistes
qui sont sélectionnés par la voix d'un
concours donc c'est un concours annuel
qui est organisé avec un jury qui se
réunit donc c'est une première phase de
dépôt de dossier de candidature ensuite
des auditions et puis les pensionnaires
arrivent en général en septembre chambre
à la vie de la Médicis et ils vont
passer une année ici avec leur famille
et en parallèle donc de ces de ce
programme de résidence on a également
plein de d'autres formats de résidence
plus courtes où on accueille des
artistes pour quelques mois à quelques
semaines et quel est l'intérêt pour ces
artistes de venir ici finalement et
d'être pensionnaire pendant un an alors
déjà c'est on leur offre quelque chose
qui a une valeur inestimable c'est du
temps de l'espace pour pouvoir
travailler pour pouvoir parfois prendre
du recul sur leur pratique donc ils
reçoivent une bourse de résidence ils
ont également un atelier et un logement
donc voilà ils peuvent aussi être en
contact avec des réseaux d'artistes de
commissaires et de centres culturel ici
à Rome mais aussi plus largement en
Italie en Europe alors vous avez dit
vous accueillez des artistes
pluridisciplinaires quels sont les
disciplines qui sont actuellement
accueillies à l'Académie de France alors
en ce moment parmi les pensionnaires on
accueille des on accueille des
compositeurs de musique on accueille une
poète on accueille un écrivain beaucoup
aussi de d'artistes représentant les
arts visuels et les arts plastiques mais
parmi les résidents pour des durées plus
brèves on a également un chef culinaire
actuellement en résidence donc vraiment
nous accueillons toutes les typologies
de discipline vous accueillez aussi donc
des expositions actuellement jusqu'au 21
mai une exposition oriente express et
Compagnie est organisé c'est une
exposition que qui est coproduite par le
festival de photographies les Rencontres
d'Arles et par le fond de dotation
oriente express avec 200 œuvres pour la
plupart photographiques qui sont
exposées donc dans les galeries de la
Villa Médicis et ce qu'on vous propose
c'est un voyage à travers l'histoire de
ce train mythique mais aussi de
découvrir les coulisses justement de ce
train et pas seulement le mythe qui nous
est arrivé aujourd'hui et puis on
découvre aussi au concept exposition
qu'il existait une liaison entre Paris
et Rome
en train qui existait depuis le 19e
siècle oui tout à fait on a souhaité
pour cette exposition sortir des
archives exceptionnelles qui font
l'objet de près et qui sont aussi des
archives de la du fondation
Orient-Express pour justement marquer un
petit peu les relations qui sont à la
fois d'ordre économique politique mais
aussi culturels très forte à travers la
liaison justement de ce train Rome
Express lui aussi mythique merci
beaucoup Aurélie avec nous je rappelle
donc que vous êtes Charlie de
communication de l'Académie de France à
Rome ici à la Villa Médicis merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site Internet et sur
notre application radio sensation on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]